living with some pain but
more
uh voice is strong
she says that as they've been doing the
lab work the potassium has been at like
130 which is not 135 but 130 is better
and she said her potassium is right
so between her potassium and sodium
might those sound like the big
how about have you got b you in and
create
she's convinced she doesn't need
kidney replacement and so
uh also would you mention to rebecca
that i'm still here
so her car has been sitting in my
driveway for over a week
all she has to do is use the triple a
card i gave her for christmas
call triple a and tell him to come
replace your battery
okay you tried charging the batteries
yes
aaa came once before
and instead of doing a permanent fix
they jumped
well she drove it around
no no no so you mean a deep charge a
this is the legislative dhhs oversight
committee
for friday january 28th would the clerk
here
thank you
first agenda item is the minutes for the
meeting of december
17th you have all received copies
to approve by senator gray and seconded
by senator rosenwald any further
discussion
all in favor
opposed
the agenda item next that i've been
given discussion on the establishment of
a subcommittee
regarding house bill
fn this came to my committee health and
human services
one of the
difficulties we're working under
presently is getting people to staff
committees that are appointed to study
items
the speaker has
not only asked me to try to fill such
positions
regarding health and human services
increasingly i've been asked to try to
fill any positions
making recommendations on who would be a
good fit
so i can tell you it's very very
difficult
there are some people who do not want to
serve or cannot for various reasons
there's other people whose skill sets
are in wonderful but in different areas
in this kind of work
and then that just leaves the people who
are already on multiple of these
committees
and i've gotten turned down most
wonderfully by so many people because
they said i'm already on five i can't do
any more so the word is coming down and
it is seconded by
uh my colleagues across the aisle in the
house that if possible can we go a
different route other than
appointing a
specific committee of house members
and senators and i hear senators are
appointed to a lot of different
committees too
and
we'll see what we can do here um
so it was suggested
to
representative yokela
that um perhaps we could go in a little
different direction to get people in an
ad hoc working group that would come
back and make good recommendations
i as chairman of health and human
services have also in a parallel track
asked four members of my committee to
brainstorm come up with some ideas not
in a formal way but see if they would
recommend some good things too so i
would record
recognize representative ocala to come
up and
speak to his um
and he'll tell us why
this bill has
importance to it and
perhaps how we should go
forward in changing
laws or making recommendations for
somebody who's techy
somebody who isn't techy but has done
and you got to be fairly near to the
you can go over there if you want sure
thank you uh chair
for bringing this
before the committee
um
uh
was
stems from uh
finding uh in our current
uh laws
that
essentially uh
in every in a bunch of situations um
syringes needles injectables like
epipens
that they don't have a prescription for
is
currently illegal in new hampshire
and um i gave um testimony as to a
number of situations you know someone um
you know doing cleanup
around the around the uh their town
um you know a friend
showing them how to use the epipen that
they've
newly been
prescribed all of those may
cause
currently in under our law
those people to be uh committing a crime
and you know one of the things that we
are are trying to do right now is not
one uh change uh that
um we don't put um
kids into the legal system unnecessarily
and to
to um
treat
if there was some nefarious reason why
they were having this
either a mental health or a substance
abuse
issue and not a legal issue
and so um
so the first part of the bill is to
to um repeal that restriction on on
minors but then there's the there's a
separate section of law that says if
the the needle syringe epipen
auto injector to a minor then that is
also a crime and i wanted to look into
that
and
so i proposed a study committee to look
into that issue instead of um
you know
suggesting my my solution to that
problem
and um
so it was suggested at this committee
hearing
that one i do my own research to to try
and come up with some language
and two to perform an ad hoc committee
um
and or a subcommittee of this committee
um to do more research um so that this
issue could be addressed more
comprehensively
um
in the near term and not um push it out
for
for too long so
since then i have reached out to
nurses school nurses association
camp counselor or camp camp nurses
i have reached out to
dhhs because we have in new hampshire a
syringe program
that
doesn't specifically
offers syringe services
to
minors but it is not forbidden and there
are states like
north carolina offers syringe services
to anyone
and one of the reasons why we do that is
is
the cdc
has has suggested that um you know
trying to
limit the syringe
uh
availability has caused blood-borne
disease problems and so we don't really
want to move forward with that and so
there's been an effort to
make syringes
not
reduce the prescriptions for adults
which which has been in a lot of places
and
just
have more availability and so i've
reached out to a bunch of people and
i've proposed and i've come up with
um what i think may be a proposed
amendment for the
adult
language the amendment would not come
here it would come to hhs and ea however
my question is
having to do with the study committee
for reasons already given it might be a
better ad hoc
group of people who meet often bills
come to us out of those
and so um are you
suggesting that that would be a better
way something that would be a work group
perhaps
perhaps is a subgroup of us uh with
one of our people being part of that and
then others that we've pulled together
we would be
if we had us some
representation from from this committee
health and human services committee
um
to be able to talk to
some of these people
um and and uh the ideas okay that come
forward anybody from the
oversight committee wanted to weigh in
representative edwards uh thank you mr
chair
um
i i'm empathetic with with the issue as
you've described it i'm i i am
personally a little confused because i i
have an understanding of how policy
committees work and how oversight works
and i don't i don't understand what an
appropriate response would be to you in
this situation i i would tell you that
personally
i don't get really really busy for
another two to three weeks so if we can
knock this out quickly absolutely i'd
personally be happy to do it
also if you're thinking about ideas of
where you could turn to maybe get some
input
right now the governor's commission on
alcohol drug abuse prevention and
treatment is is meeting and patrick
tufts might be a good person i can give
you the contact information to just give
you some advice on somebody on the
commission that might want to
participate and because you have such a
great room of
of experts here you know maybe somebody
will grab you
and say that they'd like to participate
like i see
moira back there child advocate you know
so um all right so
so i i i guess that was the purpose was
to try to find some people that might ad
hoc with him uh no
yeah but the real purpose is uh should
this be a
committee
out of bill 1616 as it's written and
we're going to probably say no in the
committee for simply the reasons of
staffing or should this be simply an ad
hoc group of people you pull together
or could it be an ad hoc group of people
that maybe finds a little home coming
under the umbrella of us for a brief
period of time those are the options we
have
doesn't have to come out of here could
be on your very own but it might
be also possible to come out of this
oversight committee anybody else with
any thoughts
insurance um programs are entirely
unfunded by the state and i think any
mandate on these programs would first of
all be unfunded
and second of all it would interfere
with the mission of the syringe service
programs which is specifically to reduce
the spread of some police severe
infectious consequences amongst the
vulnerable population so i would be very
much opposed to this
i don't think representative that that's
really where he's going he would just
like it possible for somebody to have an
epipen it's really more along that than
anything else but
i did reach out to
some of the syringe services
[Music]
people and the people at dhhs that run
the syringe services program and
to ask them if they
had the ability or currently had the
desire to
be able to serve that population the
under 18 population
um it isn't a big population because
that's
um
usually using uh syringes for nefarious
reasons is
is happening later in life like 20s plus
but there are um
but
the question that i posed to them is
should we be forbidding them from doing
that if they had the funding to uh and
someone asked for their help would
would they be opposed to that and so
that's one of the discussion topics for
for giving them an exception to be able
to service those people but it's not a
mandate um definitely
thank you
any further question on whether we
should
with one person from this
committee
work with representative yokola
as a subgroup of us that's that's the
yeah
so so so to the that question
of
whether oversight should take on
a role of mentoring or or sponsoring um
a work group like this
i i would just say i i don't know that
there's a precedent for that and it
doesn't it just doesn't feel right to me
from an oversight position i i think i
think what is being asked is more of a
policy committee issue and not
not what this committee does so i i'm
not opposed to what he's doing i'm just
trying to think functionally is if this
is the appropriate committee and it
doesn't feel to me like it is
he does have the fallback position of
being able to pull a work group together
on his own
and
i've already as i said have four people
from health and human services committee
looking at this issue and
you can pull them in if you
uh wish
doesn't sound like we have
the
votes to do this
but now we're aware of it
and i'll work with you
on
that other alternative okay
sure thank you thank you absolutely
yes sir
senator gray
i was the sponsor of the syringe
exchange program
you know that that passed
and
there's many issues
i i've tried
but um
there's many issues that go along with
that and and
you know like even in the city of
rochester there were complaints about
the syringe exchange program that was
going on there and the policing of it by
the people who were
taking advantage of it and and i agree
with representative edwards that a
policy committee is much more
equipped to deal with that
our job is to say well
certain things have been passed and
we're going to see that they are
implemented rather than try to craft a
bill
so
thank you
i think we have our answer and i'll be
back with you representative some good
ideas here we just got to get them in
the right place thank you
and
okay um
now on the agenda and sorry uh is not
sorry that it's now on the agenda but
sorry for you getting bumped down as
mr technical person on the floor has the
okay
this is okay i don't want to have my
so i just want to give a brief update on
a couple of uh key things going on in
the department
under covid right now we are evaluating
the data that we're using
as we
as we move further along the the through
the pandemic and we rely more on at home
testings things like that
data points like active case counts are
become more unreliable as we move to
more of an at-home testing base
so over the next couple weeks we are
really going to be looking at the data
that we're reporting in what is valuable
what's a value add to both tracking and
our response to the pandemic
i think when we know that
you know our case counts for example
we're reporting two or three thousand a
day it's probably double that right so
we we just ordered a million more
at-home
covet tests uh the antigen test that
will be sold in liquor store for cost so
as we rely more and more at the
at the
at-home basis we don't want to give
either
a false sense that cases are going down
when they're not
or that there's really three thousand
cases a day when it's maybe five
thousand cases a day so
i think what you're going to see is
probably a new uh
a new component of data coming out on on
what's driving our response it's mostly
going to be around hospitalizations and
fatalities it's not that we're not going
to report case data but we're going to
become less reliant on it
so that works being done over the next
couple of weeks
as i said we ordered a million at-home
tests we got approval to order a million
at-home tests on wednesday
we expect them to be in the state in
seven to ten days after the order is
placed and then after a couple days of
processing by the liquor commission
they'll be in our liquor stores
for sale
at cost plus the cost to distribute
through the liquor commission
in the prior
month we've stood up two strike teams
and in long-term care facilities one at
premier and one at ridgewood
we have a third one coming on board
edgewood on february 7th and then we
have a rehab strike team that we got
approval for on wednesday and at the
previous previous fiscal meeting to do a
rehab strike team that's coming on board
february 14th
so far with our long-term care program
where we're trying to move long-term
care residents out of acute care
hospitals and back into
a long-term care setting we have moved
64 into county facilities with the
guarantee that their medicaid would be
covered and we've moved 62 into the
strike facilities so total approximately
122 people we've moved out of hospitals
and into in a more appropriate
environment
that's it for covid
under
mental health we're expecting imd
approval so our the waiver that we
submitted last year we're expecting that
in the spring
of this year the intent on applying for
this waiver was to attract private
private behavioral health providers to
our state
so that they can run both in patient and
outpatient capacity we are hoping to
bring two projects forward in the coming
months to build our inpatient capacity
in our state through public-private
partnerships
with a couple of different entities so
we're we're still working through some
of those details but hopefully in the
coming months we'll be able to bring
those to the table
representative marsh
thank you mr chairman i don't think my
mic
is clearly
issues with the data that's being
presented with income tests i think that
the new hampshire citizens clearly have
an interest in the prevalence of coven
in our communities
two years ago i asked des if they would
look at a wastewater monitoring program
as they've now implemented in boston
because that gives
results as to what's going on throughout
the state
throughout the area of their wastewater
system and that has shown both the rise
and the fall of the front variant in in
the boston area
i do believe we have a number of
wastewater systems where that can be
implemented relatively quickly and
inexpensively in the state of new
hampshire and i reported inquired a
couple weeks ago from des if they would
consider such a thing
i'm not going to hear back from them
would the department consider doing
something like that instead so we
continue to have some data as to the
prevalence
we've used wastewater treatment programs
in private areas right like new
hampshire hospital monitor circovid in
their hospital based on wastewater tests
and unh conducts those so i can connect
with unh and see if there is interest in
expanding their programs they've done
wastewater treatment
testing for their campus
for a variety of nursing homes for the
hospital so the the the science and the
testing is there obviously
i just want to make sure that we're
connecting with the right people to see
if we can do that and are there
municipalities cities that are
interested in it you know is the city of
concord interested or city of manchester
whomever so let me connect with unh and
their wastewater program and see what
their uh their ability is to scale up
i i agree with that um but if i'm
reporting inaccurate data because
there's thousands of tests being done at
home then i don't want to give the
would it be possible when
giving the number of positive test
results
there's an immediate statement a
disclaimer saying this we believe this
number to be artificially low because of
the
proliferation of home tests the data of
which are not reported yes sort of like
the surgeon general's warning on a pack
of cigarettes yes we've used that
messaging pretty regularly throughout
the last couple of months as the
insurgent up home tests have come out
and we will still continue to report
case counts and tests but what we don't
want is as
thousands of people in new hampshire
start doing at-home tests for them to
feel like they have to call public
health and report their positive because
we don't have the resources to do that
either so we will still continue to
report case counts but we're going to
pull in other data that i think is going
to be more accurate
than the actual counting the number of
cases in the state
we have told our patients at our center
in kingston if you test at home please
send us the results we'd like to know
it's helpful in our care review
absolutely
uh i want to thank the commissioner the
vax van came to our facility in kingston
the other day and
a combination of what the vaccine people
have posted on websites and
lots of publicity from me we had a lot
of people come it was wonderful
people didn't have to come but if they
wanted to it was right there in our
parking lot so thank you our mobile
clinics have been very successful across
the state probably one of our more
successful programs
really meeting people where they are
getting into vulnerable populations
people that don't have you know
widespread transportation to get the
vaccine sites they've really been quite
successful across the state
and also especially when the local group
that's sponsoring it
is a group of people that are trusted by
the general population so that well if
dr pearson's forward i guess it's okay
that really worked well for for my
wife's patients i also want to thank you
about the increase in caring of mental
health the addition to the facility here
in concord the purchase
along the way we hope of hampstead
hospital the partnership with portsmouth
hospital in a new facility in epping
it's gotten to the point now when i pick
up the union leader in the morning to
read it i'm wondering what's next
because you're really doing a wonderful
job and getting more space
thank you i think you know we're trying
to build out the system of care
fairly quickly we've had an er boarding
crisis for
a decade now and we've spent four years
building out community-based services
we've launched our cti program today
there are rapid response programs crisis
services mobile crisis services and you
get through the continuum and you get to
that kind of that peak which is the most
expensive and most acute
uh part of the continuum which is the
inpatient beds
and when you look at national studies
they'll tell you that
inpatient beds per 100 000 should be
between
50 and 60 beds per 100 000 of the
population new hampshire is currently at
if we used every bed that we had
licensed for example hampstead is
licensed for 111 beds they're only at
45.
new hampshire hospitals licensed for 192
they're operating around 170. there's a
variety of reasons for that
so
with the portsmouth deal as we bring
that forward that would bring our uh
patient bed load up to about 40 per 100
000 a second project would bring us up
around 44 45 which is still very at the
very low part of that threshold is what
is considered acceptable
so
we're excited about bringing
new beds online to support the people
that are in the emergency rooms
they are not to replace the robust
community-based continuum that we have
built for the last four years to help
support people in the community that's
where people belong that's where people
should get their first level of care
anyways is in the community
anyone else with a question senator
rosenwald thank you
good morning commissioner good morning
um a few weeks ago i
had some conversations with
department staff about
the commercial urgent care centers
some of them being unwilling to bill
insurance telling people
that their insurance wouldn't cover the
testing even though
um
they had been exposed to someone who had
coveted so it should have been covered
has that resolved or are we still seeing
people who are
asked to pay a higher
charge-based
amount of money versus
getting their insurance to cover it
i haven't heard specifically about a lot
of cases of insurance not covering it
we've actually talked to all the
insurers who were
covering it across the board all testing
and and vaccination too
there was some question that as people
started get needing testing just to
travel and things like that it's not
considered medically necessary and i'll
check with the insurance department to
see if that that jump has been made
i think you know we have to
differentiate the difference between
going to
a testing center that is supported and
paid for and funded by the state and
going to an urgent care center for an
assessment of a respiratory illness
because they're two very different
things when you drive through our
testing site even though it's
our testing site is being executed by
clearchoicemd
all of that is paid for by our funds
when if you if you drive up to a
clearchoice md
urgent care center
apart from our state site and go in they
are going to assess you for respiratory
illness even if you just walk in saying
i want to cope a test
but by their practice they have to
assess your respiratory status so
they're going to charge you for an
urgent care visit
regardless so that's where a lot of
people are getting confused they say
that they just wanted a koba test
and they went to somewhere other than
our coveted test sites and they were
charged as a visit
um so that that has definitely had
there's been some confusion in the
public about that we've tried to
streamline that to say if you want to
test no cost go to our testing sites if
you go to one of the urgent care centers
apart from our testing sites there is a
possibility that you'll be charged your
copay it'll go through your insurance
and whether your insurance pays for or
not is going to be up to them i can
check and see if uh if the insurances
are still across the board paying for
all testing the last conversation i had
with them which was several months ago
they were across the board paying for
everything but i will check in with them
again thank you because my understanding
from
um
talking with dr ballard was that the
problem was not with the insurance
companies it was with
the
for-profit
urgent care centers
wrongly telling people their insurance
would not cover a medically necessary
test okay and they were charging some of
them over 200 dollars
for a test people could not wait for
hours in a line for the free test sites
so i'll check in with the urgent care
centers too we have two main ones in the
state
and then we have our hospital-based ones
and it'll be pretty easy to find out
thank you
anyone else
representative edwards
uh thank you mr chair i think i have
four different things i'd like to talk
about and good seeing you again uh
commissioner um the first one um
is a part a and a part b uh i i'm just
curious
if any of our our testing and statistics
gathering is making a distinction
between omicron and other variants
and if they're
or if we were set up so that the next
wave of variant is measured and reported
distinctly from omicron and delta could
i it's something i could have asked
offline but i'm just curious uh what
what the precision is yeah so our public
health lab does do genome sequencing
which can can identify covered variants
so they can identify omicron now a lot
of our testing sites don't use our
public health lab because that's very
limited
but commercial health labs commercial
labs lab core and and those types they
are also doing genome sequencing for
omicron as is the cdc in most uh most
bigger labs so anything that comes to
the public health lab which are several
hundred a day we do genome sequencing
and we have been able to identify
omicron in our in our
our testing pool um when a new variant
comes out usually we are notified by the
cdc that there's a variant of concern
and uh the cdc is the one that starts
testing samples for it before it ever
gets to us but yes once a variant is
there we can test for it at our public
health lab
and then are you reporting it distinctly
or are you putting all covert together
as though they're the same we we report
the number of variants we have a weekly
report that we send out thank you i i
have a follow-up on the home testing
i'm i'm curious about the accuracy of
the testing do do we have a sense of
false positive and false negative rates
on those um
dr ballard can give you all of that
information he was on the committee that
picked the test and they looked at both
the accuracy of the test most antigen
tests are about in the same range and
ease of use because that also impacts
the accuracy of the test so he has all
that information i can have him send it
to you okay thank you uh mr chairman i
have a couple okay so i i think this may
be an opportunity for you to brag on
your department um
about a month ago or so uh the joint
fiscal committee and the executive
council authorized some um
funding for
the booster burst or i forget what the
marketing term was for that
blitz okay that's so much better than
burst i think
but um the objective the metric that you
established for success i think was 10
000 boosters
could do you happen to know what
what your booster rate is so uh we had
two booster blitz during the first
booster blitz we were closer to 12 000
on that day the second booster blitz
which was during the snowstorm we had a
storm that morning we were right around
9 800. so for the most part we met we
met we met our objective that double is
good double is a good success story
um and then
uh on the joint fiscal committee
uh there was 12 million dollars that was
requested to to pi to buy
the home test kits that would be sold in
the liquor stores
and at that point it wasn't clear
that the uh
process procedures the accounting system
was set up so that as as the test kit
got set uh sold at the liquor store that
that that transaction and that money
would be flowing to replace the 12
million that we spent up front do you i
i'm not asking you if you know right now
but
are you comfortable that we're going to
have that under control we we have it we
we signed an mou with the liquor
commission to have that money flow back
into arp and we actually talked about it
at the press conference on wednesday
that because it's going to flow back in
and replace that money that we can
continually buy tests you know if we
sell the million tests we'll use that
money that is replaced and buy another
million tests
so we get to continue
to make sure that the supply is there to
meet demand
one more one okay one last one and this
one um it may be something you've never
heard about but i had a very agitated
school administrator
call me and the school administrator
said that she had a full-time job being
a school administrator before the
pandemic and since the pandemic
she
spends
she says uh literally all her time doing
contact tracing
and uh so her her frustration was that
her other duties weren't being attended
to and so she was just asking the
question
is there some money that the department
may have to help supplement the manpower
to do the contact tracing or
or alternatively
if this data is not
of the value of the cost of collection
can we change the collection
requirements on school contact tracing i
i don't know if you're prepared to speak
to that but i wanted to share with you
that
i i haven't been
i haven't been in that intense a
conversation in a while
so um
that's exactly the type of data review
that i had just spoke about in my update
that we're doing what is what is value
added with all of the data that we're
collecting
what was value added two years ago isn't
necessarily value-added today so we're
reviewing that now um joint fiscal just
passed about a nine million dollar
workforce public health workforce cdc
money except an expend
a good amount of that is money going
towards workforce to help the schools
during covet
seeing if trish is here she's not here
public health isn't here she has more
details on it but yes that nine million
dollars a good amount of that is is
going to the communities to help with
kobe but we can get you more details on
it
thank you so much and thank you mr
chairman
anything else for the commissioner
representative
out from the marshall's of new hampshire
but but the cdc has reported through
banker's hospital review continues to
report the state of new hampshire as
last among all the states in getting
booster doses out of the population that
has
been as is the new term up to date with
vaccination um would you like to comment
on any efforts the department is making
to address this problem because clearly
if we're not up to date with
vaccinations we're not protected against
the current variant
yes uh we we agree and we continue to
message every week for people to get
their boosters in addition to booster
blitz we have our mobile uh
site that's going around to
all of our vulnerable populations we
have a homebound program we we've just
contracted with to deliver booster
vaccines to the home we have stood up um
six plus vaccination sites across the
state to do both primary and the booster
doses
we've made we're making vaccines
available um and you know that's
that's our role we have to make it
accessible we have to do the public the
public campaigning to say this is what
you need to do to protect yourself
um
i haven't seen becker's
recently but i'm going to go look at
that article
i think part of the issue with our
booster data is the accuracy of it
because we don't have a robust iiis
system what was happening is cdc could
not distinguish between first dose and
third dose so they were repo when you
look at their reporting you would see a
very high initial vaccination rate very
low booster and what the reality is is a
lot of those initial vaccinations are
actually the boosters and the cdc
doesn't have that information because we
don't report patient specific
information to the cdc so a lot of the
national data you know
you know until we fix that iis can be
confusing
um yes we
actually um are a lot of our fixes for
that came forward to both fiscal and gnc
in august and september and was tabled
for several months before we could even
get it off the table to start the
process so yes there has been tens of
millions of dollars allocated to our
state to fix our iis system uh part of
the department's challenge is
shepherding it through the different
authorities the elected authorities to
representative nelson thank you mr thank
you mr chairman
my question uh you sort of touched on
earlier the numbers that they report on
tv seem somewhat inaccurate
when they report say 3 000 new cases
that does not of just clarification they
do not count the home desk but where do
they get that number for 3 000 or
whatever sure commercial commercial labs
and health care providers are obligated
to report to public health so we have
electronic reporting from our all of our
labs across the state and nationally and
then all of our health care providers
our hospital also electronically reports
so that 3000 number which is usually um
an incomplete number because we have
such a backlog now you know we set up a
system to report you know 500 000 cases
a day now we're getting 3 000 cases a
day so we're backlogged so that 3000
number would come from our electronic
lab reporting system for all the labs
and health care providers across our
make it five
or you can use up any leftover minutes
from representative edwards would you
share
rock on
do i have audio
uh excellent um thank you mr chairman
thank you commissioner uh my intent is
at the end of my observations that you
will simply nod and say yes uh these
remarks are for the public and for this
committee to consider
i need to give you a word of background
please i'm jeffrey salloway i'm state
representative
i have a phd from boston university in
medical sociology and organizational
development that's going to be relevant
later
in addition i've done post-doctoral
research at tufts medical school and
i've held fellowships at princeton and
the university of minnesota in
epidemiology i am now professor emeritus
at unh former chairman of the unh
department of health management and
policy
for 20 years i did research and taught
epidemiology and before that i taught at
rush medical school university of
illinois college of medicine and the
medical college of wisconsin which
should indicate to you by now that i
have trouble keeping a job
some
40 years ago i had a colleague at cook
county hospital in chicago
china had just opened up to the west
and my colleague's wife had traveled to
china and returned with a stubborn
pulmonary infection
it was unusual it was not an infection
commonly seen in a cook county it was a
fungus
it was aspergillus
and we had no effective treatment my
colleague's wife passed away
for me it was a wake-up call
i realized that there are infectious
agents out there
that we do not prophesy
and they can be lethal
so i began to watch
later in about 1990
a new book came out by laurie garrett
laurie garrett was a journalist for
newsday she published a book called the
coming plague newly emerging diseases in
a world out of balance
her thesis was that we were beginning to
see not just an epidemic here and there
or even an occasional pandemic rather
what we were seeing she wrote is waves
of infectious disease following in
shorter and shorter sequence
if you think back you will recall all of
the examples
tuberculosis
polio
hiv
avian influenza
sars sudden acute respiratory syndrome
drug resistant gonorrhea
and now covet
but
what has caused this continuing series
these waves of infection is something
that we had not previously anticipated
in the course of evolution there has
emerged what we might call a rogue
plasmid a plasmid is a circle of
non-chromosomal rna which carries within
it instructions for cell behavior think
of this as an operating manual for the
micro
this particular plasmid seems to carry
four characteristics
rapid replication
an internal protein pump which enables a
cell to eject foreign proteins such as
drugs
the ability to aid
the human
immune system in fact to outwit the
human immune system and finally and most
terrifying i think the ability to move
the plasmid moves not only from species
of one kind or another but across phyla
to move from the bacteria to the viruses
to the fungi
and to confer the infectious ability on
whole new orders
of microbes
there are numerous
alarming examples of this process
some blame uh overuse of antibiotics for
drug resistance i believe that is true
however
i suspect
that the emergence of highly resistant
strains of bacteria and viruses is not
just over use of antibiotics the
microbes are learning to adapt to us
and they evolve faster than we can adapt
to them
if you look at the example of
tuberculosis
of you who are old enough will remember
when selman waxman discovered
streptomycin in 1944 we believed that we
had a cure for this scourge and that it
was over
we did not prophesy the evolution of
drug-resistant tuberculosis and then
multi-drug resistant tuberculosis and
now extremely drug-resistant
tuberculosis we call it xdrtb extremely
drug-resistant tuberculosis
this strain is now rampant
throughout russia and is spreading
westward toward eastern europe
laurie garrett then wrote betrayal of
trust her second book and in it she
examined public health systems worldwide
her predictions her prophecies were
predictable
our current public health systems are so
underfunded
understaffed
and forgive me incompetent
that they betray our trust that they can
safeguard our public health
i've taken a close look at the guardians
of our public health the world health
organization
is underfunded
and incompetent to meet the challenges
that is
upon us and it is corrupt
here in the united states i've watched
i've worked closely for decades with the
fda cdc and nih
i avoided the fda as it became a
creature of the drug industry
i resigned from study section at nih
when i watched the old boy corruption of
investigators who were funding their
friends
though i have had a love affair with the
cdc
i've watched the destruction of morale
and
the compromise in the commitment to
scientific integrity in favor of
political expediency
as for our own new hampshire department
of health and human services i have
worked closely with that department for
over 30 years
i've done work for them they have done
work for me and in all those years i
have never not ever found
either incompetence nor a whiff of
corruption in any member of that
organization not ever
however
here in new hampshire we do not provide
that department with the necessary
resources
to deal with what i am prophesying is
coming plagues
we are not a poor state but we are cheap
a doctoral degree from boston university
confers on one the privilege of donning
the red robe of prophecy mr chairman yes
sir you have heard the words of some who
bear the burden of those red robes we
celebrated martin luther king's birthday
just a few days passed
some find that burden unbearable
and seek escape and prefer to remain
silent i can no longer remain silent
here today i must speak out
we did what we could in kovit
but we did poorly and we continue to do
poorly
we are unprepared and will be so for the
next round of infectious disease
we need to be proud of our department of
health and human services
but we need to do better
so what's coming what's down the pike
possibly mutations of covid this
probably isn't over
likely we will see two new variants of
avian influenza one coming our way from
the middle east and one from china we
will see nipa virus
most assuredly we will see and we are
seeing drug resistant fungi they are
here now they are in our hospitals now
nobody in the hospitals wants to talk
about it but they're here we have drug
resistant clostridium difficile this is
old news you've already heard about that
it is imperative
that we find a way to strengthen dhhs to
help prepare for what is prophesied we
need prevention we need surveillance we
need quality data we need the
availability of treatment for all
so
thank you for listening thank you mr
chairman for the privilege thank you
commissioner for putting up with me i
can only hope that new hampshire will
find ways to deal with what's coming
thank you
as one possessing a doctorate from
boston university i am prepared to grant
continuing education units to anyone in
anything the commissioner might like to
do besides nodding
we're in this together folks
yes representative edwards you still
have a few minutes left okay so um i
just received a great education there
and as i'm thinking through that i'm
thinking about the military whenever you
know somebody brings a problem to the
table they're supposed to also bring a
solution
and i and i and i heard in there
um a solution from professor
representative salloway
that suggested that we needed to build
out the public health section of
our department
do you have any initiatives underway to
actively
look at the kind of resourcing that
would be required to at least begin
moving in the direction
representative salloway is
we have the
general infrastructure in place for
example we have their regional public
health networks unfortunately they are
dramatically underfunded under resourced
uh they're not able to do the work that
they're that they're supposed to do now
during covid we increased their funding
we gave them the resources they went out
and ran a lot of our vaccine clinics
they did a lot of our testing um they do
a lot of our school-based clinics for
our kids so they have the ability in and
the desire to go out and do the work
they do we just don't fund them enough
and i think that extends right into the
department so our division of public
health um when we were at our max of
doing contact tracing and when we were
trying to um
to track kovid in in the communities
you know we went from a staff of having
10 or 12 investigators to having you
know 150 um and we had to get temp staff
and national guard staff to help us
so
yes we have the infrastructure and we
know what to do
but i i i don't think that
the funding is there beyond covid right
now we're using arp dollars to be able
to fund
the the work that we do
we accept the federal funds that come in
that that helps so we have the nine
million dollar workforce grant which
puts people in the community that's
where public health needs to be
needs to be not the prevention and the
fighting needs to happen in the
community not on hazen drive and concord
we are one unit but we need we need to
have our community help our public
health workers in our community in our
with the people the vulnerable
populations
so the
the answer is yes we have the
infrastructure but we don't have the
funding or the resources to stand it up
one follow-up
uh does this feel like a 10 million
dollar a year
fix or 100 million dollar a year fix
what's your instinct on this um i would
just put let's put it in the middle
there i don't think it's 10 million by
any means um i mean we saw how fast
we spent money during covid um i i i
think we spent you know 100 million
dollars in the first six months of covet
between ppe and
and temp staffing so in normal
non-pandemic times it is not 100 million
do you sense we will ever get back to
normal times absent any coming pandemic
do i think we're going to exit the
pandemic yes but i think as as the
representative said that um
we're always going to be under threat of
some kind of public health risk whether
it be
covid or drug resistant fungi or
something like that i think we need to
be prepared for that and we've seen that
through the years with different
respiratory viruses that have
made its way through our community not
being staffed and prepared for it seems
to me to be far preferable to a panic oh
my gosh do we ever have to ramp up at
the next emergency you know i think you
know our disease investigators dr daley
dr chan um both that worked at public
health dr daley has moved on to a
national position now but
um you know i remember our first days of
the pandemic
you know sitting down with them and
saying this is your world series this is
what you've been preparing for your
entire professional career and we had
very you know they're very competent
very very um
knowledgeable people our state was very
lucky to have their their
skill level in our in such a small state
and i think they did remarkably well but
you're talking about having a dozen
people running a pandemic i mean the
same people that runs this pandemic are
the same people standing up our mental
health system are the same people
dealing with the sud crisis and same
people dealing with you know family
planning it's all the same people so
even the the staff at the department are
gonna burn out i i mean there's two two
years of
uh of this heightened reactive
crisis work standard that we have
endured for two years at public health
and all over the department
representative marsh
to ramp up our interaction with the town
health
officers association
okay
next on the agenda federal public health
emergency enrollment unwind update
associate commissioner
christine santiello
and we'll see if that microphone's
working there i
can you hear me oh wonderful
thank you so much um
i'm chris santaniello and
good morning for the record henry litman
the medicaid director and you had your
vacation postponed i'd like to believe
because you wanted to be with us but we
know the real reason
so we i shared with you all a really big
packet um
but we're not going to go through all of
that today you have a big agenda beyond
us what i think we want to just give you
some high level information
on
the continuous coverage of medicaid but
also
how we're handling the end of the
continuous um
coverage because that's really going to
be important to you all all of you on a
budgetary employee
let me interrupt for one second we've
got so many piles of wonderful stuff
what does it look like that one that
you're holding does it look like this
yep we're not and we're not going to
walk through it all we're going to skip
all over it to confuse everybody thank
you but we just want you to be aware of
the potential budget impact as well as
what we're doing today to help your
constituents because we all know that
you will probably be hearing from your
constituents
just on a high level
we're really been working with many
partners and internally we've been
meeting weekly
since july of 2020 every friday at 8 15
if you need henry or i or our teams we
are on a weekly call to talk about what
we call the unwind
and our goal is to really ensure those
that
are eligible for medicaid
don't have a gap in coverage because if
people don't fill out the paperwork and
comply with our request they will have a
gap in coverage but also transition
those who will no longer be eligible
to really work with them to transition
to them to other coverage
and we've we have a lot of partners that
we've been working on so henry's going
to talk now about the numbers
chris before i do that you might want to
just speak for a moment
make sure everybody knows what we're
talking about public health emergency
that's a federal declaration started
under president trump
has been continued
under the new administration president
biden but basically it's the
declaration that allows the federal
government to provide additional
federal matching percentage which is
currently 6.2 percent
reduction in what the state share is
and
within the public health emergency
the department
had the option to sort of scale back
what it was doing and maybe you might
speak to that sure we we did have the
option to scale back some of our work
but we never stopped we continued to
process applications we continue to do
redeterminations as
as they were due in
in the sense that we wanted to keep
people covered even if we did our
redeterminations and the person was no
longer eligible
they continued to be eligible so we
never stopped working we continue
because we're integrated eligibility so
if a family comes in and does their
application for snap we immediately look
at their
data they're providing and try to
continue their
eligibility for medicaid so we were all
systems go and we continue to be doing
that as we continue to work
through all of this
so
i'd like you to in the packet that's
been passed out jump out to slide seven
because i think this
in a in a small picture
today the
the on slide seven
um at the top there just above the two
circles the medicaid population as of
last week was over 235 000
individuals everybody everybody with me
um
and what we've shown here are two
circles here um
they're the important part on the
left-hand circle is the
86 038 individuals who are at risk of
losing coverage
and then on the right
we have
that broken down into
nearly 29 000 people who we know based
on information the department has on
hand
unless the individual has a change in
circumstances that we're not aware of
that would lose coverage
at the end of the month in which the
public health emergency ends and
that the population that's on your in
your grace
spot there
we've been working with the insurance
department on and the navigators to make
sure that they're aware of their options
because there's nothing we're going to
be able to do
if their circumstances aren't different
other than that they're going to drop
from from medicaid coverage
there's
on the left hand side of that
right hand circle is the 57 000 plus
individuals today
who are
have an overdue redetermination
while we continue to do the work and
continue to process redeterminations
individuals during the public health
emergency weren't requ are not required
to
to do it it's a voluntary thing and what
we've been messaging is that
it's smart
if you will
to
um
take the risk
out from your your family situation of
not having coverage by doing the
paperwork that you need to do now
because at some point
there's going to be
a huge influx of people you know that
all at once that are going to need our
help and what we've been trying to work
on for since july of 20 is to spread
that work out so we don't have this huge
tsunami of individuals needing help all
of a sudden and we're not able to
respond to that
and as chris talked about earlier we've
been working with um all sorts of stake
stakeholders
in um getting them to uh work with the
beneficiaries to to to navigate this and
it involves for example our mcos it
involves the mental health centers
federally qualified health centers
anyone who has um a relationship under
hipaa where they can use information
we've actually been providing
information to those entities that in a
compliant way that allows them to do
reach out and most recently the
department
has implemented
a program where we're making outbound
goals to um
to individuals who are
the most at risk the most vulnerable
people who are in long-term care and i
know you're going to talk a little bit
more about that maybe you might want to
do that now yeah so um
so what we've been doing is because um
we actually um through um fiscal
committee and and um
gopher we had some additional funding um
we've been able to add call center staff
so that when calls come in
they are triaging the calls which has
freed up some of our department staff to
process applications we've also used
those staff to do outbound calling to
call some of our individuals that we
know are behind on their redetermination
and and we consider them to be
vulnerable they may be elderly they may
be disabled and doing outreach calls and
doing those using our family service
specialist is when the family service
specialist gets the person on the phone
many times they can process their
redetermination while they have them on
the phone so that has been extremely
successful
we've called 87 percent of people on a
list and we reached 38 percent of our
target population and so we keep on
going back to making those phone calls
and at the same time we're sharing this
information publicly we're doing you
know through our social media post
working with our stakeholders to say it
really is us calling we're calling we
want to help you get through this we're
doing everything we can to try to help
people remain eligible
so that as henry said when the end does
come which we don't know when that is
it's you know we are continuing to plan
not knowing on when that end date may be
to just be better prepared
so
in terms of if you look at slide um
eight
sort of a breakdown of the
population within medicaid over time
if kind of look at it from just since
the start of the public
uh basically the march 18th i believe is
when the
state of emergency was declared
our population has grown by about 57 000
individuals enrolled in medicaid
we think that
and this is an estimate that
approximately
of the
that extra enrollment are people who are
new to medicaid and about 77
represents those who are
what we call protected status because of
the public health emergency with
continuous coverage
um and so
i think that
you know we're going to see
[Music]
a drop in in the number of people
covered by medicaid what we just want to
make sure is that's appropriately done
so so that
when you are thinking about this in
terms of the constituent calls you might
be taking
that that we're helping the people that
need to be helped and when you're
thinking about it from a budget
standpoint that we're doing our job in
terms of making sure that eligibility is
and so we take some questions i think at
this point
yeah i had heard that there was a senate
bill that helped
people who were in danger of losing
coverage um
either senator if you know what i'm
talking about i'm not quite sure i do
uh you'd have to provide me some more
information tonight okay i do not
recognize it from what you've said okay
the only one i know of is um extending
postpartum
yes coverage that could be the one
you're thinking of could i ask a
question i think so yes yes thank you um
of the 57 000 people who are
uh overdue
on the ready
how does the department have an
expectation of
how many are going to be
ineligible i'm trying to get a sense of
what you think the total caseload is
reasonably
you know within the emergency ends but
separately
how many
children do you think we're going to
lose
so we in fact this morning on our 8 15
call we're starting an outreach campaign
to to start to call families we're
starting with the youngest and most
vulnerable making outbound calls we did
that with the the home with the
disabled and the long-term care people
it is a concern
that those children don't lose coverage
in terms of predicting the overall
i think that we're going to get back to
a somewhat
free pre-pandemic level
at the end of the public health
emergency but it's affected honestly by
the federal policies in place
for example
[Music]
back in
the beginning of 21
it was our understanding that
um we would be able to use information
that we had that was as old as six
months to be able to make
redeterminations more recently the
guidance has changed in in august of
this past
year that we have to do a
redetermination on everybody
and so
and that we can only
reduce from coverage with a build back
better act which
was another potential change
in in what we could do that would be
limited to how many individuals could be
disenrolled in a given month uh to i
think 112.
right now the buildback better component
is not
is you know that isn't moving
legislatively as it stands right now i
think it would take us approximately
between three and six months to get back
to a normal level it depends on what the
runway that we're working on now
in terms of all the outbound calls and
all the other activities that we're
doing
and in in addition to that senator um
some of those children
are eligible for snap and tanf and so we
use that opportunity
because those are not under continuous
eligibility so we use that interaction
and that data when we meet with those
families to also look at the medicaid um
pieces so while we have them to say can
we continue to push them out in addition
we're working closely
with the new hampshire children's trust
as the facilitating organization for the
family resource centers and providing
them as our partners with information
showing them how to work with families
in new hampshire easy so we're really
trying to
work with all of the natural community
partners as to where people will go and
providing them information and our
message is really simple please do it
now
so that we can keep you um
covered because we we don't want people
to have a gap um due to the high number
of applications and redeterminations
coming
in thank you but the tanf case load has
been
low
because of
stimulus payments
so
what is the department doing to
automatically
re-enroll people who
will be
eligible as soon as outside sources of
we can't automatically enroll people
people have to either be eligible or not
eligible but we're continuing to work we
have a whole page on our website called
um you know cove the pandemic unwind and
really trying to connect people and i
think one of
the
one of the silver linings of all of this
is the increased communication and
because we're we're integrated we'll be
saying to providers okay we're here
talking about medicaid but here's other
programs that we need people to continue
um to apply for we're working really
closely with new hampshire employment
security and and their staff um and
really just trying to work with
everybody who touches a family to
provide them with this information
final follow-up thank you so
going back to my first question
does the department
i i think you're
i inferred that you think we'll get back
to a fiscal year 19 case load
with about
the number of
children
that could
i don't have an exact number on on
children that i think would be the case
but i think you know our enrollment in
children has increased during the public
health emergency we're certainly going
to
make that a very high priority that
if there's a child that's eligible that
we've we've made
multiple attempts to to get to them um
but in terms of just the enrollment
number if you if you think about um
that
approximately 20 um 23 of the growth in
enrollment
you know if if that were to stay
and nobody were to change we'd probably
um end up about 10 000 or so above
and i think that again it's going to
depend on what federal policies are in
place in terms of what our flexibilities
are if we're limited to for example only
disenrolling 1 12 at a time
that's going to be a different
unwind
also just to to mention in addition to
the numbers that are here the state of
new hampshire through
the public health emerging what we call
the covid testing
group it's now the covid testing and
treatment group there are approximately
um
9 000 individuals today who are in that
group above this but their coverage
automatically ends at the end of the
public health emergency if you kind of
think about that group it's sort of the
public health group in the sense that
they're making sure that people are
getting tested in treatment and that one
was only
the only eligibility for that was that
you didn't have you're uninsured
and so that that group uh
um
more recently is also had access to
treatment which is a benefit to
everybody when you think about it from a
public health standpoint
but there's a lot of work to be done
here and and it's uh
doing the mission of taking care of
people but it's also the most important
thing i think in terms of managing the
state budget with respect to medicaid
representative edwards uh thank you mr
chairman um
i i don't remember exactly when i first
saw the i.t strategic plan but one of
the priorities for early
adoption and upgrade
of an upgrade was the eligibility
module
and as i'm listening to you your
struggles with
trying to process eligibility issues
it makes me wonder
what the status of that it upgrade is
for the eligibility module
and if that and if that upgrade's going
well if that's going to help you
so
yes
um
and we're always looking to make
improvements to our new height system
because again that is our integrated
eligibility system i think um
unfortunately because of the public
health emergency we've had to do
a number of different
programs and different services so
in an effort to respond to some of the
community needs such as like pandemic
ebt some of this medicaid unwind some of
our
regular
work towards enhancing the system has
gotten delayed but yet at the same time
we're making enhancements all the time
because of the public health emergency
so we're moving ahead but we still have
and i guess i would say also too in
terms of working with our
vendor partner in this respect that
what we're able to do um in terms of
preparing for this i think
i put new hampshire's status up against
any other state in terms of um being
prepared both to help beneficiaries and
the next agenda item is
one that is mine and i'm going to wave
it off
so that we may devote
as much time as we have to the
subsequent items
designated no excuse me system review
of complaints about nashua children's
home mariah o'neill child advocate
office of the child advocate
and we have
um
reports
from you that
look like this and i believe they've
i believe we have these
that look like this
thank you
extras
okay so this this is a good sound check
here
better okay thank you
for the record my name is moira o'neill
mr chair thank you for having me today
to speak on
behalf of the office of the child
advocate and make comments on
our report on the nashua children's home
to start with this morning i'd just like
to do an outline about
the office of the child advocates
mandate
the framework under which we conduct
reviews our methods of review and then
i'll walk you through a very brief
summary of the prompting complaints and
incidents and subsequent analysis i
understand that you've had a copy of
this report already so i didn't think i
needed to go thoroughly through this
it's a 30 page report with responses on
it
if you prefer at any point that i just
answer questions i'm also happy to do
so the mandate of the office of the
child advocate is that we are an
independent and impartial state agency
statutorily mandated to oversee
state-provided and arranged services for
children
to assure the protection of their best
interests and to promote effective
reforms
in terms of the framework under which we
operate
you can imagine that independent
oversight
of publicly provided services is complex
there is plenty of research including my
own doctoral study that demonstrates
imposing investigations and adversarial
relationships are not successful in
achieving long-term change
the traditional approach to oversight
that employs blame and shame that
generally results in someone getting
fired or a program being shuttered is
only a short-term fix
there are broad and complex systemic
factors that influence individuals and
their decision-making when you fire
someone the system problems that allowed
that person to operate the way they did
remains and the problem is not solved
and you're left with difficult
relationships making it hard to engage
folks in change and quality improvements
so with that understanding the office of
the child advocate has instituted a
framework of safety science to conduct
our reviews and guide our relationships
and oversight
safety science is an evaluative science
used in safety critical industries like
aviation and nuclear power it has no
tolerance for error but it holds the
system accountable rather than any one
individual who's operating in a faulty
system
with safety science we create a safe
space where people can comfortably see
the value in honesty
self-examination
and constant learning when people feel
safe reviewing actions and events they
are more willing to be honest about
those events and decisions made
in that space people are empowered to
problem-solve with long-term solutions
it's an approach that actually improves
practice in the process
so the biggest obstacle to this approach
is when people are unable or unwilling
to see the value of open honest
examination of events
taking a defensive tactic to feedback
closes doors to opportunities for
learning and therefore improvements
none of this will work if people don't
believe we can always do better
so i appreciate your indulgence and
letting me explain that framework
we're very aware that our approach is
different than other forms of oversight
such as licensing and special
investigations
both of which have very different
mandates through narrower lenses
so the method of our review
typically when we receive complaints or
we notice trends and incidents that are
reported to us is that we wait for
systems to play out we hear the goal is
not
oversight of the program but oversight
of the internal mechanisms of system
oversight including licensing special
investigations and general case work if
we observe that processes that are given
attention to practice and events
thoroughly then we may not see a need to
proceed with that with a review
our first step is to assess the
credibility of complaints this we can do
by reviewing immediately available
records of cases or investigations we
want to be sure that complaints are
timely relevant and associated to some
established obligation for provision of
service or standard of practice
sometimes the complainant
may appear not credible
for example you may hear that
complainants are disgruntled former
employees
our focus remains on the credibility of
the complaint
and not the complainant
once that's determined and we have
concerns and also in the context of our
own available resources to conduct a
review we may bring the complaints to
the program or agency to gauge their
response
and assess whether they might not be
able to address the complaints
internally
if we find we have to proceed
we employed our statutory authority to
access information and begin review of
all available records policies program
descriptions
relevant state and federal laws
contractual obligations we conduct
interviews with relevant parties and
experts we visit or observe photos and
videos
we conduct literature review of
standards and practices models of care
and outcomes of both
um so that gives you an idea of uh the
sense or a sense of how we review how
we'd conduct a review
so before i launch into the details of
our review i want to make clear that
nashua children's home is not the only
residential facility for which the
office has received complaints or
observed troubling trends in critical
incidents
please keep in mind we are still a very
new agency the first review of any kind
is going to stand out it should not be
assumed this review is any indicator for
measuring comparisons with other
programs
so the office of the child advocates
review of nashua children's home was
prompted by two sources of concern
we began receiving formal complaints
about nashua children's home on march
2020 that accumulated to about seven
complaints
i used the word about because in
addition to those we examined carefully
as we spoke with people and it became
known that we were looking at nashua
children's home there was a snowball
effect of either additional complaints
along the same themes or general
encouragement to proceed with the review
because of ongoing concerns with the
facility
the second source of concerns were noted
trends in the incident reports that the
office receives for all facilities in
particular as pertain to the use of
physical restraints including prone face
down physical restraints
we followed the process i just shared
with you we met with the program
director we shared some complaints to
determine whether he recognized them as
problematic and how he was responding to
them
with persistent concerns after speaking
with the director we met with the
president of the nashville children's
home board of directors and subsequently
sent a summary of concerns to all board
members
throughout this process we used themes
of concern that emerged from the
complaints and incident reports as
reflection of a gener general program
culture
we asked the question do does this
action reflect the program's values and
education of staff on the latest
knowledge of child development or
trauma-informed care
we ask do the actions that are subject
to the complaints reflect the mission of
the organization
the response received from the director
and the board was mixed
we appreciated some change in policy and
promises regarding staff training the
commitment to pursue accreditation
promise that some program changes would
be required
but we did not get the sense that the
program leadership either understood or
embraced the deeper meaning of the
concerns as they affected children
in the meantime in june 2021 nashua
children's home signed a contract to
provide residential services with dcyf
this was a groundbreaking event for new
hampshire prior to that moment the state
never formally contracted for
residential services and therefore was
never in a position to hold providers
accountable to certain standards or
types of care
we saw in the contract an opportunity
for a good framework for reviewing the
concerns from nashua children's home
and it turned out that we could
categorize complaints and incidents to
match requirements in the contract this
would give clear path for improvement
for going forward
and as a reminder the office of child
advocate does not have enforcement power
we are completely reliant upon the good
faith of the department and the program
to recognize the value of examination
and learning to ensure that the best
services are available for children and
that services don't further harm
children
so there were three major themes that
emerged from complaints and incident
reports
they involved trauma-informed care
orders of authority and permanency
so we reviewed certain
nashua children's home practices that
were associated with complaints for
their negative or adverse impact on the
child that they included
isolation or removal from community
physical restraints and certain staff
interactions
in examining trends in the use of
physical restraints at nashua children's
home we noted the practice of isolating
children from their peer community that
appeared to be an antecedent
in incidence of physical restraints
as a means of both calming and punishing
the national children's home removed
children from their peer community to a
space referred to as the quiet room
they do not report using seclusion
because to circumvent the statutory
definition of seclusion they post a
staff person in a room containing small
stalls where children are placed staff
refer to this as extended separation
the dual purpose of the room may be
therapeutically confusing for children
one former resident told us children
hated the room and that was evident in a
random sampling of 54 resident
restraint incidents 83 percent of which
involved a threat or a move to the quiet
room
in addition to trending use of
restraints we examined experiences of
three children who were restrained one
for 80 minutes in a face-down prone
position
in terms of the staff interactions that
we felt were associated with
trauma-informed care
a child to we looked at a child being
repeatedly told he was just a kid in
treatment that no one cared about
and another whose image was posted on
social media in a demeaning way that may
have been referencing the child's
medical condition
nashua children's home reported the
posting was not considered problem
because they had no policy at the time
against people exposing children's
images on social media
upon complaints from the staff a policy
was
established to gauge the program's
appreciation for the violation of
confidentiality and the potential trauma
of public exposure we asked to clarify
whether the policy was established
because staff complained or because it
was the right thing to do we were told
it was created because staff complained
to all three types of practice
complaints
involving trauma the facility response
seemed to one distract from the lived
experience of the child and two dismiss
all of what we've learned in the past
few decades about the impact of trauma
and adverse childhood experiences
specifically
keeping connected not isolating is the
most effective intervention to promote
resilience and inspire positive behavior
children must feel they are valued as
part of a community
loss of control in physical restraint
exacerbates trauma and is viewed as
violence versus problem solving the
over-reliance on external control of
children precludes success in nurturing
internal controls and coping strategies
demeaning or making fun of children and
their circumstances in general aligns
with the american academy of pediatrics
definition of emotional maltreatment
that new hampshire recently codified as
a form of abuse
we made the point in the report that
understanding the law and acting within
its confines is important but that only
represents a minimum standard for safety
and care not the best practice
in 2019 new hampshire addressed that gap
by codifying senate bill 14's mandate
for all children's behavioral health to
be trauma-informed and evidence-based
this is a standard that's aligned with
the best practice in the best interest
of children
in terms of complaints around responding
to orders from authority there were two
orders that the new hampshire that
nashua children's home was reported not
to have followed one involved a child's
access to court appointed primary caring
adult
a primary caring adult is a person who
agrees to be involved in a child's life
without the caring responsibility
there's a rigorous vetting process to
approve a pca reflecting the importance
of the role and relationship national
children's home interfered with the
child's access to that pca
the second case involved special medical
orders that were not followed the very
clearly stated
the orders said that the child should
undertake a daily routine but with
purposeful privacy and that the focus
was ordered to be on the child's comfort
level and not on the outcome of the
routine instead it was made into a
reporting activity that made the child
and at least one other child feel
uncomfortable
in both cases the disregard of orders
reflected both a lack of understanding
and communication with either dcyf or a
physician
in terms of complaints that fell into
the
the theme of permanency
the new contract that new hampshire
nashua children's home signed with the
state reflects the federal family first
prevention services act that's grounded
in the science of child development and
trauma-informed care
the law and the contract
are designed to promote shortened
episodes of residential care rapid
reunification to families
or community and intensive supports in
transition to permanency
this week we examined nashville
children's homes census data for the
current month we saw that of 33 resident
children stays ranged from 99 days which
is about 3 months to 1 903 days that's
five years
there are 17 residents who have been at
nashua children's home for more than a
year nine for more than two years and
five for more than three years dr
o'neill i'm going to interrupt you now
we are very pressed for time here uh
would you sum up briefly please we can
read all the documents sure and that in
that section so so what i was getting at
was that in the re
there were some interference or reported
interference of uh planning and
transitioning of children out of the
facility
that when we got a response from the
facility about that
it was notable that the the director
felt that children should have stayed
longer regardless of what happened to
them otherwise which may be other cases
that should be brought to us but it sort
of
reflected a feeling that um that there's
a belief that children should stay in
this facility for a long time which was
counter to the contract and also counter
to federal law
so i just i did give you a graph um
this is updated data that does show that
there's a slight trend in the use of
physical restraint in the facility uh
but if you're a if you are a statistical
master then you'll notice that while
it's significant we can't really explain
it as time it may just be that there's a
different constellation of children
there
and also this the graph on the bottom
demonstrates
the reasons why
children are restrained the things that
happen prior to the restraint
and it appears as though perhaps it's
not necessarily
as the as the as the organization is
starting to report more and document
better we're able to see that the
reasons for using restraint may not meet
the legal
legal expectation for restraint which is
emergencies in case of self-harm or harm
to others
in many cases children are just not
following rules refusing to go to bed
and doing things what most kids do um so
i can conclude there um so those were
the findings um we we generally were
concerned about a culture in the
facility that didn't quite get the um
the necessary sort of switch and and
paradigm switch in in culture that the
contract and the federal laws required
that we start to look at kids
as um as really needing to
only have very short stays in
residential care um moving out and and
being trauma informed and evidence-based
so that everything we do for them
actually helps them um when we look at
kids who leave and the director points
to them as
their failures being because they left
the facility one has to ask the question
what treatment was happening to those
children while they were there that
would prepare them to leave after such
long periods of time
under the federal law children have to
be assessed frequently now um to see
whether or not the program is even
effective if a child is there for a year
or more and still is not able to be safe
in the community then then that's not a
good match for the program i mean you
all stop there and take questions will
you take questions
uh representative
mcmahon
thank you mr chairman um ms o'neill just
uh specific to page 16 on the report and
i
wanted to ask you what the
recommendations you may have on this and
update on what treatments that being
taken place or comments on what can take
place
when it's referring to it can be quite
negative from what i've been reading
just so far
uh is is there any recommendation that's
being proposed to
address social media
um
adding being being added out there from
patients being handled at this location
sure thank you for the question the
opportunity to clarify so um so the so
the uh so the nashville children's home
did establish a um policy after this
event
based on staff complaints that would
that that prohibits any um
exposure of children's images and
comments about them on social media
we were surprised that it wasn't thought
about in terms of hipaa and other
federal
laws that require confidentiality we
have state laws that require
confidentiality of children and
children's care
and and beyond that as i said the the
laws around those sorts of things are
important but that's a minimum standard
really understanding the impact of the
effect on the child when they're exposed
and and trying to understand a culture
that would do that to children and we do
see a lot of studies right now looking
at how even parents are exposing their
kids on social media and the negative
effect that it has and the lack of
respect that it demonstrates to the
safety and well-being of children
follow-up
but just to get a clarification here so
i don't misinterpret what's being
proposed what's uh stated here it said
that this issue was resolved with the
advert of policy and training does that
mean it's now eliminated as an
opportunity to take place going forward
so we are told that there is a policy in
place and that that staff have been
trained about it we have not received
other reports about postings about
children at
national children's homes so we assume
that that problem is resolved
there is also an absence of policy in
the state level in terms of
confidentiality around social media
exposure that is probably should be
addressed
it sounds to me like
you're saying and i'm trying to condense
a lot into a few
brief thoughts but you've received
complaints about this facility
you've investigated the replay
complaints
you probably had a chat with a few staff
members
you did work and you are working to
change
how the system is working but nobody
ever needs to be fired
is that a good summary of what you've
said well i would say that if you if
you're looking for someone to fire
you're not looking for the problem
there certainly are there certainly are
times when people need to be fired for
sure
but generally people don't go to this
kind of work with the intention of
harming children and and also i would
there have been times when um and it's
happened at nashua children's home and a
couple of other residential programs
where
staff came to work and
exposed children to using substances and
doing other inappropriate things and
they were fired for that but i would
argue that there's still a system
problem that allowed a person like that
to be hired and not supervised and let
that happen so there's a there's a
systemic problem there that's not
resolved just by firing people i see
anyone else
thank you so much
and the chair now calls a bunch of
people
david bob stacy
megan
rihanna
and you'll have to decide amongst
yourselves who you would like to
a couple of you come up and maybe then
mr chairman members of the committee my
name is david billy i think i'm the
executive director of nashua children's
home
also with me today are our residential
director matt fentross who's been with
us 13 years and long time board of
directors member bill dwyer
nashua children's home began as the
nashua protest protestant orphanage
association in 1903
i've had the privilege of serving as its
executive director for the past 36 years
um one of the things to realize when we
talk about and i
have a few you know comments on on miss
o'neill's report
um which i've submitted to you our
response you have her response to our
response what you don't have is our
subsequent response to her response to
our response which i want to get into a
little bit
um but as far as as as permanency goes
one of things to realize
is that
we have no legal relationship with the
boys and girls placed at nashua
children's home
we're only their 24-hour caregiver
but we are we do not have a legal
relationship so as far as their movement
towards permanency um that's something
that's not uh anywhere nearly entirely
in our in our control i i do want i do
want to cite um
one of the things that miss o'neill
spoke to which she references in her
response to our response where she says
twice in your response you promoted
lengthy stays at nch for children which
belies an understanding of the federal
family first prevention act
which you know limits the amount of time
children spend in residential facilities
if you look at those the specifics of
those examples though
one example involved one one case
involved
a brother and sister who came to us at
the age of six and seven years of age
left our facility at the age of nine or
eight nine years of age uh went to a
foster family that we thought honestly
was
ill-equipped in terms of the physical
energy to keep up with these two little
kids who were a lot honestly
uh three weeks later and we could be so
we still though gave that foster family
a lot of input from the child's
therapist from our senior staff
from a number of other people those
sessions involve the cpsw involved they
go to the casa as well
three weeks later these are these are
two kids that when they were at nashua
children's home and they were with us
for two years
lived on separate boys and girls units
but had
had visited with each other every single
day
the dad was deceased the mom's rights
were terminated as far as family
contacts they had each other and that
was it and they visited visited with
each other every single day they
attended charlotte avenue elementary
school in nashua they made friends at
school they were invited other kids
birthday parties at school
when the foster placement disrupted
after three weeks where they returned to
resident nashua children's home no
they were placed in separate residential
facilities one out of state one in new
hampshire where they attend those
facilities on ground schools and in the
subsequent 15 months
and this comes from the report of the 10
year old girl who still calls us from
her out of state facility in the
subsequent 15 months this brother and
sister who had had daily visitation at
nashua children's home have had zero
face-to-face contact with each other i
really don't think that's what the
federal law intends when they talk about
permanency
zero
contact with each other the second
example involves a 17 year old girl
who came from a family that had
documented sustained substance use
she had that herself
when she was with us at nashua
children's home she was employed at
hanford supermarket she gained her
driver's license
she was educated at a local alternative
high school which nashua children's home
paid for by the way not her school
district nashua children's home funded
the enrollment in the in the alternative
high school
and the plan at that time was to have
our transition to our transitional
living program which is a program for
kids that age out of the child
protective and juvenile justice system
and can't return home and receive no
financial support from their families of
origin we provide housing for those
young people we provide continuing staff
support and guidance for those young
people
at zero cost to the state of new
hampshire or the federal government that
program is funded almost entirely by
private charitable contributions
that was the plan
with one day's notice she was returned
to her biological family
after which she became pregnant and
dropped out of school again is that the
intention of the family's first
prevention act i don't think so so those
are a couple of the examples um a third
one that's not really it's mentioned
specifically in miss o'neill's report
and i'll comment on it because i mean
all of us have seen some of the uh news
pieces on the tragedy occurring in
manchester with a seven-year-old girl
and i know miss o'neill also mentioned
kids missing from residential facilities
and mentioned the risk that involves
that's increasing with kids being
sexually trafficked
the boy that was physically
restrained in our quiet room
had a history of being sexually
trafficked
made a move to leave that facility
and be on the streets of nashua where he
would be at risk again for being
sexually trafficked our staff mr
fentross being one of them
had to make a split-second decision do
we allow that kid to leave and be on the
streets at great risk to himself or do
we stop him from leaving
we stopped him from leaving
after which we
after which followed an eight-month
investigation
investigation conducted quite honestly
by people from either their offices or
from their living rooms during the
pandemic
judging people that show up at nashua
children's home every single day
during this pandemic and bring their
best efforts on on the behalf of
of of the boys and girls that we have
there
mr fentroughs will be at nashua
children's home 8 o'clock tomorrow
morning stay until 11 o'clock at night
and remain overnight as well you know
and that's one of the difficulties that
comes up with this kind of uh with this
kind of procedure i i would say that the
report
charitably
is fast and loose with the truth um we
know nothing about a kid being told he's
just a kid in treatment the difficulty
with some of the some of the complaints
is that the complaints were never
presented to us with sufficient
information in order to respond we know
nothing of that complaint as far as the
social media piece
it wasn't the case that the policy was
instituted because of staff complaints
but once the complaint was brought to us
that image was taken down within
literally two minutes
and then the procedure was it was
implemented there's not been another
complaint towards that end you know one
of the difficulties
that um we encounter
is that there's a belief from not all
you know state workers but a lot of um
in the child protective and juvenile
justice field
that
our type of program and i think i speak
for all resident residential providers
that we're an institution an onerous
institution that does not give kids the
the love and understanding and care that
they that they that they that they need
um
couldn't be further from the truth i
mean these are people that show up for
kids every day love these kids every day
i mean there's an effort
going on to
basically save kids
from organizations like ours
um
i think there's a lot of other feedback
that could be gleaned from from talking
with other people too about their
experience at nashua children's home and
what
and what they've had um so i think that
the report really
belies a lack of understanding on some
of the rigors
of residential group care that we don't
just care for individual kids and when
we need to sometimes take kids off of
their units it's because it's upsetting
to the other kids it's disruptive the
other kids it's scary to the other kids
you know so um we need to respond in a
way that that takes into account the
sanctity of the group as well um
and that people do need to then make
make split-second decisions what i would
what i would suggest that that that you
do and i know i've quoted the report
generously is look at the contrast
between miss o'neill's report
and look at the report that came from
carf international the accrediting
agency
miss o'neill's report was based on
complaints that came in
from a number of different people was
based on an examination of records
never came on site talk to me talked to
the president of our board of directors
talked to no one else associated with
nashua children's home
carf international's report was based on
a surveyor spending three full days in
our facility
talking with staff talking with kids
observing our interactions observing our
culture
her report is is clearly stated in the
in the information that's been that's
been conveyed to you
so i mean i would suggest that you look
at the contrast in those
in those reports as well
um
so i think that with uh
with that um i mean if you look if you
look at
um
when we make recommendations on what's
in the best interest of kids we're not
necessarily looking at
some of the statistical information or
looking to see how many kids that we are
able to transition to
um
to less alternative settings to less
intensive settings we're making
recommendations based on what we think
will result in the best interest of that
kid what will
what will result in them having the most
productive adult life so making our
recommendations based on that specific
kid's best interest
not looking to fill um any type of
statistical aggregate
um in with that i think i'll uh
close my comments and take any questions
that you might have
uh thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions i um i've been at
your facility uh i've walked through and
uh
i was left with the impression
that you have a lot of young energy and
lives in there who are coming from
largely dysfunctional situations
and it's very difficult it's a very
difficult role that you you play and so
i just
you've been leading that organization
for what 37 years 36 years yes yeah so
other than your choice in football teams
i i have a lot to commend you for that
but um i would like to
um
go back to the first
example you gave us of the nine and the
eight-year-old yes
i you brought that to the committee
i think that's child abuse
and so i would like to know what the
system is going to do
in order to repair the damage that's
being done to those two kids
we would like to know that too we were
prepared to take those kids back they
left in october of 2020
and we were under the impression
because we um
lack of a better word we fussed about it
for a long time thinking they should
come back to us
we had christmas presents already for
those kids to come back a little bit
later on um it was really at the
objection of the casa in this case and
supported by by dcyf that they did not
return to us and they continue again
based on the reports of the 10 year old
girl
that they continue in separate
residential facilities with no
face-to-face contact 15 months later
we would take them back tomorrow sir
i may not have heard you exactly
correctly who's standing in your way
we have no legal relationship okay with
the with the boy and girl so we can we
can't make that happen they would need
to be referred to us uh by dcyf and in
this case you have a casa involved as
well okay thank you do you have a what
involved a casa a court appointed
special advocate
okay yeah
senator thank you
um
i have to say that i was
really shocked about the social media
posting of any resident because to me
that
violates
hipaa
and risks
really big fines
but um
i understand you've
changed that that's taken care of when
it was when the discomfort of staff with
it was brought to my attention it was i
it was taken down within two minutes
and there's thrilled about that
but i have a specific question about the
use of restrooms yes
um we've heard there's a legal standard
about when they can be applied that's
correct
um
and over the last few years the state
has made a public policy decision about
the
trauma-informed care of children
that was done in senate bill 14 from a
few years ago
what is the specific
currently
at the nashua children's home are you
only putting children in restraints if
they are at risk of self-harm or harm to
another or or harm to others um having
been again one of the things and having
been around a long time um i was uh very
involved with the creation of statute
126u back in 2010
and in fact i demonstrated the physical
intervention technique that we used
across the street in the senate
conference room during the hearings on
that
and if you look at the specifics of that
kids can be physically
it's it's it's appropriate to use
physical intervention when there's
imminent risk of substantial bodily
injury
to sell for others
it's also though permissible to
put hands-on kids to escort them from
one place to another
and there are times and they happen
quite regularly we're in the process of
doing that
that child becomes a risk to himself or
others in terms of their physical
aggression
so that does happen i mean i would say
that our
and this and again as i as i referenced
earlier one of the one of the challenges
in working with groups of children is
that sometimes we need to affect that
removal of a kid from their group
setting because of the effect that it's
having on everybody else
you know our numbers have dropped the
other the other thing i would i would i
would point out about our experience
and this i think is certainly true that
we accept kids into our program
that other new hampshire programs won't
accept specifically because
of their history of physically
aggressive behavior and then more
importantly
we maintain our commitment to those kids
despite their having intensive
difficulty with that
no one likes to put their hands on kids
and physically manage kids it's the
least palatable part of the job that we
that we have however when we need to do
that we don't then end that kid's
placement with us i mean those kids stay
with us we maintain the commitment to
those kids
and um i mean there's been some some
literature that refers to physical
intervention as a as a therapeutic
failure
um which i strenuously object to because
the situation we have is this
we have kids that are referred to us
that have have a history of being
aggressive to self aggressive to others
self injurious injurious to others
when we accept them into our program
there's an understanding that
that behavior is not going to stop
simply by the replacement with us that
will most likely continue
when it continues and we stop that boy
or girl from hurting themselves or
hurting somebody else how exactly have
we failed in doing so so what we see
happening sometimes is kids come into
the program they need those kinds of
controls for a while and then those
kinds of then those episodes dissipate
and interestingly we find out oftentimes
those kids form the closest
relationships with those staff that they
know will keep them safe when they're
representative edwards uh thank you for
the follow-up
this this may be for uh the commissioner
or or mr ribson i i noticed she started
taking notes around when i mentioned the
child abuse
comment
and with without uh predisposing what
the outcome ought to be i i would just
appreciate it if you
could have sort of an independent review
of the facts and so your own
professional
judgment uh so that we could
have you share that with us
what can we do to help
there was a couple three years ago we
had a special study committee to try to
address parity in the group homes
uh i don't know what came with that
study
have you been getting a better rates of
pay we have sir uh so what else do we
need to do i i think you're probably
still mostly dependent on charitable
giving
uh we're somewhat dependent on
charitable giving as i when you visit
nashua children something one of the
examples i use was that
i go and i say i make a presentation a
group of general motors executives and i
talk to them about their product being
making cars and that if that car costs a
thousand dollars to make they're able to
charge fifteen hundred dollars for that
car nashua children's home our product
is residential care and special
education if our product costs say a
hundred dollars we charge 90 for it or
85 and then we do write letters to you
and your friends and neighbors seeking
charitable contributions as far as what
else i mean one of the challenges that
we have right now is the is the staffing
issue
and i think that one of the things that
would be helpful
is is simply more appreciation to those
people
who as they put us can probably make
more per hour the person that pours
their coffee in the morning at dunks
probably makes more per hour than they
do
and they still want to do the work they
still want to show up to work every day
it's hard to do that
when they're going to be continually
judged and investigated
by people that honestly have never done
the work i mean i would say that with a
lot of the criticism of the physical
intervention a lot of the
criticism of some of the advocacy groups
i think i'm correct in saying that for
the most part none of those people have
ever been in the position
have to respond to a physically
under-controlled child
so i think it's rather than having the
criticism how about the appreciation for
the very difficult work that these
people do emotionally physically
mentally showing up every single day i
think that would mean a whole lot to
those people to do
thank you
thank you mr villardi now the chair has
to do something
that
no chairs like to do and that is to say
we have three additional
presentations to make
that in order to do them justice
is going to take a while
i'm going to move them to the 25th of
february and move them to the top of the
list
so that
if somebody's presentation gets cut it's
a new one that day not the ones of you
who are here however i do want to
continue on this because we have a few
more people i'd like to hear from on
this specific thing
so the designated receiving facilities
our friend dr sai charila's presentation
on child fatalities
and the new hampshire health officers
association annual report with great
apologies you are being moved to
february 25th
we will continue uh this presentation on
this particular subject of nashua's
children's home so thank you director
appreciate your being here
uh thank you mr chairman members
i have two uh groups of people to call
on one is um megan rihanna and stacy the
second if you wish
yeah if you wish you don't have to but
i've been signaled by the person to your
right
who might like to speak as well
okay
so next
yes sir i apologize but i do have a
commitment i understand and i will
review the rest of the
on the video
chair now calls megan rihanna and stacy
and
uh thank you uh
chairman uh representative uh pearson
for the opportunity to speak here and to
the committee uh members themselves i
also want to thank uh
see that uh
senator rosenwald stepped out for a
moment but i appreciate her outfits were
instrumental in in moving things
up it's hard if i take my mask off here
okay i don't think i'll take it off too
speak it uh in terms of the time frame
uh chairperson what uh how long do we
have
tell you as long as you need as long as
you're brief and concise okay all right
my doctorate from bu was in a liberal
arts field
i appreciate the uh openness there so um
just in uh introducing myself and bob
keating i'm a former uh
staff member of 30 years at nashua
children's home as a consulting clinical
supervisor i came there at the
initiation of the executive director
david billiotti first as a board member
and then served
subsequently in that position
to my right is rihanna bazinati who is a
licensed independent clinical social
worker who is a
therapist at
nashua children's home uh we have megan
who is also a licensed independent
clinical social worker
at children's home former and uh uh
stacy martin who is a uh masters in uh
social work uh again a therapist at this
at um in this position
um
sir could you give us your name again
yes the name is uh the name is uh bob uh
so
this um
hearing is much appreciated um and that
on the oversight of
what had been happening at st
excuse me the previous places i had
worked also for 30 plus years in fact
that's where i met
david
that's how he and i uh uh uh
knew each other and uh it's almost 40
years in fact that i've known uh david
so it's a good way of saying that that
in fact that i come here in this whole
process with a
great deal of
of struggle
at least initially in it because i felt
and still do a tremendous loyalty to the
work at nashua children's home i've
respected the work that david has done
or much have done over the years but
increasingly over a period of time i
felt more and more
problematic
the
people that i was supervising were
bringing
stories to me that were
extremely uh troubling uh and uh
did not fit for what i would call a
reasonable standard of uh care
so the
purpose in coming here is is to hope to
take a look at both the oversight system
for uh national children's home moving
forward
uh but also for in uh in the larger
perspective residential programs uh uh
in in general um and i have to stop at
this point in time to the over oversight
uh system i don't know if uh if uh
director o'neill is still here
or she's right in the doorway i i cannot
say
enough
about the comprehensiveness
of what she has done
and looking at the report because the
conversation
in here had to do somewhat with
permanency
and also restraint
let me relate that we have four people
here
former employees of nashua children's
home who all left
well at least the three therapists left
because of the atmosphere and the lack
of responsiveness not just by
the executive director but also by the
board
and i've i have reached out to
one of the board members who is here
today and i'll speak about that right
now
so the brief history of uh the
complaints and remember this group here
is one of seven different groups there
are seven complainants here i don't know
how many people that's that's not
disclosed in terms of the report so
we have
former employees
we have former residents we have family
members we have foster
parents
we have division workers
administrators
from dcyf who are also
complainants here we have lawyers for
children who are part of the
complaintants here
we also have
legislators who are part of this process
so that's the scope of
things so to walk you all through this
and i appreciate and give me a signal at
uh at times when uh uh that you know and
i'm pressing on the time element and i i
know that you'll uh you know do that yes
sir
so
this
this begins the process at least for our
group here uh begins in may of uh 2019
and it begins and please uh you know use
our person at any point to jump in or
megan or stay seat at any point uh that
uh you want to add here
because they are the people that had the
direct experience i heard it through
them and then in my conversations with
the executive director on most of these
issues that we're going to address so it
begins with this social media post
i want to highlight this social media
post is not simply that a posting of a
child was placed that certainly is a
privacy issue
this is in
documents that we have we have sent to
as you look down the list here from dcyf
the charitable trust unit uh and the
office of child advocate it begins if
you
have the pictures here but it's
inappropriate within this setting uh to
show you that but it's a posting
of a uh
m girl uh nine years old at that point
was she was she
yeah she was eight okay she was eight at
that point in time this is the this is
the girl she is known as rose in the
office of child advocates
report
so an elias name on that
she is the girl that
that she had medical conditions which
involved gastrointestinal tract
issues she also had been sexually abused
she is standing here
and
you can picture this
with a staff member a male staff member
holding up a face cloth
and the face cloth um is looking soiled
and it was posted on an instagram of a
supervisor of a supervisor from this
unit and it said uh is this
makeup or is this poop
that was what the girl looked uh
distressed
and crying and subsequently this same
girl becomes on the subject of a filing
around some similar issues not on social
media law
postings but also around her medical
condition that you heard referred to by
uh director o'neal in in her uh in her
report so the problem here immediately
takes place because it wasn't simply uh
that uh that it was a social media it
was inappropriate by any measure that
this occurred
it was inappropriate that a supervisor
did this and it was liked by various
staff members of that unit and it was
liked by the executive director
rihanna
and stacy
brought these concerns
to the executive director and i think
you have some sort of flavor if you've
read the report and especially the
addendum to the
office of child's advocate it was
minimized it was
belittled as being not significant
and
frankly i mean please correct me at any
point in time there was what you
experienced as an intimidating
atmosphere
excuse me this is very important that
we're here and it's recorded so
from my perspective close to the mic as
the therapist of that client at the time
and i want to start off thank you bye
for having me
i worked at nashville children's home
for three years and i loved my job at
nashua children's home i loved my job so
much until i did not love my job anymore
and it started with this incident
of it
being brought to my attention that my
client was being shown on social media
in this way i would meet regularly with
dave that's what the therapist do you
meet with him on a weekly basis for
supervision to review court reports
caseloads
and i presented my concern to him
i presented my concern to him
and it was immediately i did not say how
i saw the social media post i just said
that i had been witness to it and that
was immediately met with
defense
he called out the other therapist's name
who had brought it to my attention and
tried to turn blame on her for doing
something else
i told him that that was not my place my
concern was that this happened and that
i felt there needed to be a larger
conversation with the staff in regards
to the clinical treatment of these
children because even if it was a
mistake and boundaries sometimes get
crossed between staff and what they do
we needed to have a larger conversation
about this if they felt comfortable to
do so
as i said that and i quote he said you
therapists and your ethics i don't buy
into it
this is the continued reaction to me
from this point on until i left the
agency
i felt that as soon as i felt that
something was
against the staff i think that's how it
was viewed that i was attacking staff
which was not the point i had concerns
about my client and i felt that this was
appropriate to have a larger
conversation about it i felt that any
other clinical decision that i made
until i left was met with
almost harassment
i felt that i was being micromanaged
i had two clinical supervisors at the
time i had bob
and then i also had to pay for another
outside supervisor because his didn't
count toward my licensure
i had the feedback from the two of them
this entire time
i gave my notice because i also felt
that the complaints that were being
brought up it was not only minimized but
the concerns of the staff people that
were
acting in these ways seem to be getting
promoted and the decision-making in
regards to how the therapist had a voice
within the agency seemed to just not
really be inexistent and i did say that
in my letter of resignation that i felt
there had been shifts in decision making
that went against my clinical judgment
as a therapist and this is why i was
leaving once i gave my letter of
resignation it came to my attention from
another client
that she had concerns for the same girl
in the social media post
that she was being forced to report her
bowel movements to a gentleman staff
member on another unit this
very much concerned me but of course
this was from another client i brought
it to my clinical supervisor
created a plan with this client to have
a non-leading conversation
which i did have a transcription of it
has been given to the office of child
advocate and it did confirm
the concerns of this girl feeling like
she did not have a choice in the matter
she felt uncomfortable she felt she
could not talk to staff about this
because she felt she would be called a
liar because she didn't say something
sooner and i'm talking every day she was
from what i heard had to make a call to
a male staff member on another unit to
describe
her bowel movements
so mr chair can i can i make a point
here or a question sure
okay um i i know that uh when our
selectmen
start to deal with personnel issues they
they they go into closed session that
there's an exception for 91a
and
i'm not minimizing anything i i would
stipulate that every criticism that's
been made is a valid one
uh i i'm just concerned of uh whether or
not to use the legal terms the accused
is going to have the opportunity to
confront their accusers and and whether
they have due process to introduce
evidence on their behalf
because it's it's sounding
a little
judicial and and
in your maybe the experience of some
folks who've been on this or you
where where are we going with this if we
if we were to step i'm asking the chair
at this point if if we were to stipulate
that every criticism criticism and
concern were valid
i would like to know
what it is we're supposed to do with
this information and
you know
that was a question that the chair will
take i'm just about ready to close the
hearing for this reason
we have presented
from
three different kinds of sources
to get the big picture
we're not a court
nor are we a government agency with
authority
we're an oversight board
and i think we've done it
the question is where does all of this
go
next
i realize it's been in the process but i
don't see it having been resolved yet
and to be fair to the executive director
to the former staff
and to dr o'neill
we've got to figure out as an oversight
board
with input i hope from the commissioner
and a few others
what do we recommend
next
so i realize not
everyone here has testified but i think
what we've got is enough
to be able to
make the best
determination as we can about now what
so
i'd be happy to hear not now and
certainly not uh as a group
uh from other members of oversight as to
what you think and certainly from the
commissioner and
other parties with standing
so with that i am closing the hearing on
this particular item and indeed on
okay
um i'm going to look at if child care
licensing did an investigation yeah so
some of that so i think that met with
them yeah so i need to go back and look
at what their findings are from a
licensing point of view there's a
um
okay
is
but this conversation also just got
derailed
right
so i'm going to be talking about the